ANKUR KOTWEL: Welcome everyone
to an Android
Developer Lab Plus.
For those of you that are
joining us for the first time,
Android Developer Lab Plus is
a show where we go into-- we
do deep dives in
Android topics.
So this week, we're talking
about the Maps API version 2
that we launched for Android
late last year.
We did an introductory
dive into it.
And this is a little bit
deeper into some
more advanced topics.
So firstly, let me
introduce myself.
I'm Ankur Kotwell.
And I'm a developer advocate
on the Android team.
And I'm joining you from
Sydney, Australia.
I'll pass it over to Jan
Felix, who's next.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah,
I'm Jan-Felix Schmakeit.
I'm a developer programs
engineer on Android.
And I'm also based in Sidney.
TONY CHAN: Hi, my name's
Tony Chan.
I'm also a developer advocate,
coming here from Hong Kong.
So, hello.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Great.
Yep, great.
Thanks Tony and Jan-Felix.
So Jan-Felix is one of
our newest recruits.
You've probably seen him on
the Santa Tracker video.
And if you haven't, please go
and have a look at the Google
Developers Live presents Santa
Tracker for Android, which
heavily uses the Map View API
that we're going to be
discussing today.
So that particular session goes
into more of the process
behind building the app, the
vision, and really how we make
full use of the Map
View API library.
So with that being said, let's
now move on to today's
presentation.
So Jan-Felix, perhaps you
can get us started.
Are you able to see the slides,
just to confirm?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, yeah.
Looks all good from here.
ANKUR KOTWEL: OK.
All yours.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: OK.
So, yeah.
So the last [INAUDIBLE] class
was giving you a bit of
introduction into the Map View,
kind of getting started,
getting your first project up
and running, getting the API
key and stuff set up.
And so this week, we will
look at some of the
more advanced topics.
So we're-- if you could
go to the next slide.
We're going to actually show
you a bit of code.
We're going to show you a
few examples as well.
So we're going to talk about
InfoWindows because there are
different types and ways you
can create Info Windows.
We're talking about
polylines and--
yeah, polylines.
We're talking a bit about
Camera animations.
Because that's one of the
really cool features and
something that's really
impressive
in the new Map View.
We're going to talk a bit about
markers, in particular
custom icons that you will
have on markers.
All the demos and all these
samples are actually from the
Map View demo project.
So if you want to follow along,
want to look at it
later on, you can just get the
demo project from the SDK and
just look at the code
from there.
OK.
And I think with that
we can then dive
into our first topic.
So InfoWindows--
I'm sure most of you have
seen these before.
So an InfoWindow is basically
pop-up that's
attached to a marker.
So when you click on a marker,
that's when the
InfoWindow pops up.
And one thing here to remember
is that you can only have one
Info Window at a time.
You tap on the marker, and you
get one of these pop-ups.
So let's look at the demo.
There are different types of
InfoWindows you can set up.
So you tap on it, and you get--
that was the default
InfoWindow you can get.
There's a custom InfoWindow
contents.
And you can also have a complete
custom InfoWindow.
And we're going to talk about
them in a bit more detail now
to show you how you can actually
go about creating
them and setting them up.
ANKUR KOTWEL: So Jan-Felix
--sorry to cut in-- what I
might do is just play that one
more time because they go a
little bit quickly.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Just talk
us through that video
again, could you?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yes, sure.
So the first thing-- we have a
default InfoWindow, we have a
title and a snippet, then we
have a custom info content,
where we have-- it looks like
a normal InfoWindow, like
default one.
But we have our own content
in there, our own layout.
And this is the custom
InfoWindow where we have our
own layout.
We have our own backgrounds.
It's completely done by us.
We have some more examples later
on in the presentation.
You can see exactly what it
looks like and what the
differences are.
So let's look and the
InfoWindows in [INAUDIBLE].
So I just said, there are
three different types--
default.
And the default one is basically
where you have title
and snippet, just basically
just plain text.
You can't really customize
it any other way.
You can specify title, You
can specify snippet.
When you tap on a marker,
that pops up.
Custom contents--
that's where you can actually
replace a content that goes
inside an InfoWindow.
So you keep the bubble.
That's the default InfoWindow.
But you can actually put
your layout in there.
So you can arrange text
in any way you want.
You can put your own views
in there and so on.
And a custom InfoWindow is going
to be completely replace
the entire InfoWindow.
So you can have your own Info
bubble, use your own
background, and make it look and
style it how you want it
to look like.
So let's look at--
Let's start at the beginning.
Let's look at an example for
one of those default
InfoWindows on the next slide,
on the slide here.
Basically, all you have to do
is you have to add a marker.
Obviously, you have to
set the position.
And you just set a title
of the snippet.
And as soon as you set the
title, the Map View knows that
you want to use the forward
implementation of the
InfoWindow.
So in this case, it
automatically knows if you
have a title in bold.
And you have a snippet there
in the lighter grey color.
And that's all you have to do.
And that's your default
implementation.
So it's really easy to get
started with that.
But what if you want to do
something a bit more advanced?
And you want to put
an image in there.
Or you want to style text
a bit differently.
Or you want to have different
textures in
there you want to update.
That's were custom
content comes in.
And the basic idea is that you
keep the fourth InfoWindow
bubble, so you don't have to
worry about adding the outline
to it, making sure it's
centered and all
that kind of stuff.
We just supply a
view, a layout.
That's basically what's drawn
inside that InfoWindow.
So if you look at some code--
let's look at the layout.
So basically, what we're doing
here is we are using a normal
layouts XML file that
you've used before.
And in this case, we have
a linear layout.
And we have image
view in there.
And then we have another--
sorry, another linear layout
with text view and another
text view in it.
And basically, all we're
doing --if you
go to the next slide--
is basically just inflating
that and returning that.
And the way out go about
this is by using
an InfoWindow editor.
You basically have to register
this InfoWindow editor.
You have to create an
Info Window editor.
And basically, there
are two methods.
There is the getInfoContents
and getInfoWindow.
When you just want to override
the content of it, all have to
do is return the view you want
to have in the your InfoWindow
from the getInfoContents
method.
So whatever you want to put into
the InfoWindow, you just
have to return from
getInfoContents.
And in our case here, the render
method that we're not
showing here, all we're doing
there is just inflating a
layout, just as usual.
We're setting our text viewer.
We're updating the image,
view, setting the image.
And that's all we're doing.
Then you're just returning
the view at the end.
And that's how you
can have custom
content in the Info Window.
If you go next slide, you can
see there's a custom Window.
And then you can see you have
a bit of a gradient in the
background.
So InfoWindow [INAUDIBLE]
a bit of a gradient and the
corners around it as well.
And they basically it's
the same idea.
You just supply a view.
And that view gets thrown
as the Info Window.
So you don't get the default
bubble around it.
You just get your view
that you've returned.
So if you look at the code, the
only difference, the only
thing we have changed is
basically we've added a
background to it.
And the trick is to--
if you've used a Nine-Patch
for that.
So Nine-Patch means that the
image gets scaled up
automatically and stretched
in way that makes sense.
In our case here, we're
stretching it so that you
always have a gradient
at the bottom.
And you're not stretching it
past the nose at the bottom
that sits on top
of the marker.
And that's the trick to it.
And that's your you custom
Info Window.
If you look at the code for
this-- again, we're using an
InfoWindow editor.
But this time, we have to return
the view from the get
Info Window method instead.
So you have to return null from
get Info Window contents,
otherwise that's the one that's
going to be used.
So if you return null there and
you're return to the view
in get Info Window, that's
all you have to do.
And that's what gets
drawn instead.
Yeah, so that's really
quite simple, right?
So you know how to
inflate a layout.
You've used layouts in
[INAUDIBLE] before.
But there are few issues with
InfoWindow, a few things you
have to be aware of.
One really big thing is that
InfoWindows are not live.
So it's not like any other
view [INAUDIBLE].
It's not like other views
you've used before.
So basically, the Info Window
gets rendered to a canvas
beforehand.
So you can't change the
text on it live.
You can't change the
image that comes.
You can't have custom
controls on it like
other buttons or something.
So you have to be
aware of that.
So you can't change the text on
it unless you recreate the
InfoWindow, you hide it,
and display it again.
And because it's rendered in
such a way, you also can't
have other listeners on it.
So all you can do is
you can register a
InfoWindowClickListener.
And basically, you get an event
back when somebody taps
on the InfoWindow.
So by default, it just
hides the InfoWindow.
But that's how you would
hook into that.
Yeah that's it, all
about InfoWindows.
And I think now we have Tony
telling us how to draw an
Android in Sidney.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Actually,
Jan-Felix, before we just go
ahead, I'm just going to go back
a couple of slides, just
point out a couple
of things here.
The interesting thing is on this
custom window you showed,
you mentioned that we
have a gradient.
And we can provide our
own border for this.
And you showed us a
Nine-Patch here.
The important thing to realize
here is things like the shadow
for the window is something
that we've added in on
Nine-Patch itself.
It's something the library
won't add for you, right?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, that's right.
So if you want to have the
shadow behind it or anything
else, you want to take back
on [INAUDIBLE], you
have to do it yourself.
You basically have to provide
a different image there.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Yeah, so it takes
your image verbatim,
including the little triangle
that you see at the bottom
that shows that this is the
marker that it's coming from.
So just keep that in mind as
you use these more advanced
InfoWindows that you
provide everything.
The more custom you go,
the more you have
to provide as well.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, yeah.
That's right.
ANKUR KOTWEL: OK.
Thanks for that.
Tony?
TONY CHAN: Yeah.
Thanks Jan-Felix and Ankur.
So for polylines and polygons,
we do have some samples in our
type of project.
But it's only showing lines
and rectangles or circle.
So I want to do something a
little bit more interesting
today and show you guys
how to draw an Android
figure on the map.
So next slide please.
So before that let's go take
a look at a quick demo.
So this an Android centering
on Sidney.
So we can just play around
and move it.
And also we can treat the color,
the transparency, the
alpha a little bit.
Right now, I'm changing
the color.
And then we can adjust the
width of the border, the
borderline as well.
So it's just a quick demo
showing what you can do with
polylines and polygons.
Next slide please.
So basically what polylines and
polygons do is allow you
guys, developers, to draw
shapes on the map.
One thing that's very important
is the location, the
points you specify, is in
a particular order.
So we'll talk a little more
about that later.
Basically, all of these location
coordinates are
latitudes and longitudes.
Polylines will display
as line segments.
And polygons will just form
lines enclosing an area and
create a shape.
But pretty much both
of them built from
coordinates, from points.
Next slide.
Yeah.
Both polylines and polygons,
they share common properties.
For example, you can change
colors, the widths, and the
visibility of those objects.
And for polygons, because its
a shape, so you can also
change the fill color as well.
Next slide.
So here's a quick [INAUDIBLE]
input to show you how to add
the polylines on the map
quickly and follow
the same path,
just like adding markers.
So you have Google Map object.
And then you just do
an AddPolyline.
Then you specify a
polyline options.
In this here, you add two
coordinates and then it will
draw the line for you.
Next slide.
Here's an example of how you
change color and width.
One thing you notice is the
polyline options object will
return itself after you
set a parameter.
So that allows you actually to
change all these methods.
So in this example here, I can
change the color and the width
at the same time in
one line of code.
It's like--
Yeah.
Here in an another example
of how to add a polygon.
So for polygons, also follow
the same patterns.
You specify a polygon option.
You just need to provide
a list of LatLng.
So here you can provide
more than two points.
And it will draw the
polygon for you.
So we'll go dive into a little
bit more detail how a polygon
is drawn in future slides.
Next side please.
ANKUR KOTWEL: So Tony, I
have a question here.
TONY CHAN: Yeah?
ANKUR KOTWEL: As you can see,
the labels show up on top of
the polylines.
I believe markers are
the same, right?
Markers will always show on top
of a polyline or polygon,
rather than the other
way around.
TONY CHAN: Yeah, I believe so.
And also there is, in the API,
there's a scene [INAUDIBLE]
concept.
So if you have multiple
polygons, things like that,
and you can actually arrange
these polygons in a particular
order using the index.
ANKUR KOTWEL: That's really
useful to know.
Thank you.
TONY CHAN: So one thing I want
to point out for polygon is
the points you specify must be
in counterclockwise order in
order for the field color
to work correctly.
So let me use the diagram here
to explain a little bit.
So if you draw--
let's say you have a
sphere, a circle.
If you draw a line, a circle,
within the area.
If you draw it counterclockwise,
the thing
actually enclosing in that
counterclockwise circle is the
area actually the color
is going to be filled.
So in the case here on the
right, you can see the circle
is in the clockwise order.
So if you try to imagine you're
looking from inside,
from the back--
so it's actually the outside
area is actually enclosing.
If you try to imagine,
like it's
actually enclosing within--
if you draw a circle
anticlockwise.
So that's why when you try to
draw a polygon, you always
have to think about drawing it
from a counterclockwise order,
so that the right area
is going to field
the color you want.
It takes a little bit of
thinking to try to imagine the
right hand side.
But this is something you
want to keep in mind.
Next slide.
For polygons, you can also
change the color and width.
And the method signature's
a little bit--
the name is a little
bit different.
So for polygon, it's fill color
and then stoke width.
Next slide.
One thing interesting about
polygons is it allows you to
create some holes.
So in here we call it hollow
polygon, within a polygon.
So one thing--
I used this concept
to actually draw
the eyes of the Android.
So for the eyes, you just need
to specify some points, so
that the API will draw
the circles for you.
And after that, after you
create those two circle
polygons, you add it to the
original polygon using the
method at hold.
And that's how I achieved the
effect of having a transparent
eye for the Android.
Next slide.
So here is--
as I mentioned before, we're
going to talk a little bit in
more detail how to draw
the Android body.
So the digram here shows what
kind of points you need to
specify in order to achieve
the effect of having an
Android figure body.
So the first point is actually
on the right, the top right.
And then you try to draw the
semicircle shape using a whole
bunch of points.
We will talk about how to
generate these points using an
equation later.
And then, after you draw the
semicircle, you need to create
a straight line on the left.
So that's why you need to
specify another coordinate on
the lower left corner.
And then the last one is
the lower right corner.
And after you specify all these
points, the API will
just connect these dots together
and then fill the
shape with colors
you specified.
Remember, we're using the
counterclockwise principle.
And that's why enclosing area
is in green in this case.
Next slide.
So now it gets to the
equation part.
So how to draw that
semicircle?
So it turns out if you go to
Wikipedia and try to figure a
way to draw a circle or
semicircle, you will find an
equation like the one
showing here.
It looks pretty complicated.
But it will help when you look
at a figure like this.
So this is a general
ellipse equation.
And the phi angle is--
if you try to actually shift the
ellipse from the x-axis.
So in this case, the b is the
short distance from the center
point of the ellipse to the
phi of the ellipse.
And the a is actually
the longer
width side of the ellipse.
And acmyc is the center
coordinate of the ellipse.
But the good news is if you're
not trying to draw a curve
actually with an angle, you can
actually greatly simplify
this equation much further.
So next slide, please.
So if we set the phi to zero,
then actually everything
becomes much easier.
Because a lot of sine, cosine
parameters will become zero
and cancel out.
So we have a much simpler
equation here, which is just
the center point plus a cosine
theta and b sine theta.
So the theta part allows you
to draw, to select some
points, samples, so that you can
use those point to draw it
on the map.
So the next slide will show
you some code-- how to use
that equation.
So here I create a
polygon options.
So let's say I want to draw 400
points to get the curve.
So in usual case, if we want
to draw a circle, the phase
variable you probably want
to use 2pi divided by
the number of points.
But in this case, I want
to draw a semicircle.
So instead of 2pi, I use pi
divided by number of points.
And then you have a full loop,
going through all these four
hundred points.
And apply the equation, this
exact same equation you saw on
top, but in code.
So you use the center of
the city you point at.
In this case, I am
using Sidney.
So xcmyc is the color coordinate
of Sidney.
And then a and b is the width
and height of the Android head
you want to have.
So it just some numbers and then
multiply by sine theta
and cosine theta in this
case in the equation.
So this way you can generate
all these points for you to
draw the Android figure.
So I hope that helps you guys
understand how to use polygon
and polyline [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
Yeah, thanks Tony.
That looks really quite cool.
Yeah.
So now that we have a few things
on the map, let's talk
about animating the camera.
We have an example here, a
little demo, that shows you
some of the features
that you can use.
This is, again, straight
from the API demo.
So basically, you can
go back and forth
between Sidney and Bondi.
And the Camera animates.
So we're changing the
orientation, change the rotation.
We're changed the tilt.
You can zoom in and zoom out.
And everything is animated.
But if you don't want
animations, you can turn them
off as well.
So you can jump straight to
a particular location.
And that's what we're going
to talk about next.
So if you go to the
next slide--
so we're moving the camera.
So there are two ways
of doing it.
So either you can animate
the camera.
Or you can move the camera.
And animating means the camera
actually moves from point A to
point B. So it's animated.
And to do that you have to use
the animateCamera method on a
Google Maps object.
And basically you supply
a CameraUpdate.
That's mandatory.
And the CameraUpdate basically
says, this where the Camera
should point at next.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
The next thing--
you can supply its duration.
So we can say, OK, how long
should the animation last for?
And you can register a Callback,
so you're notified
when the animation's cancelled
or is finished.
But if you don't want
animations, you can also move
the Camera.
That's in the next slide.
So we can basically say,
on my Google Maps
object, move the Camera.
And all you have to supply
there is just the
CameraUpdate, which tells
you where the Camera is
going to point at.
So if you go to the
next slide--
let's talk about and
these CameraUpdate
objects a bit more.
So basically, a CameraUpdate
object tells Google Maps how
the Camera should move and
what the Camera point at.
At to create one of these,
you just use a
CameraUpdateFactory.
And basically, there are a
couple of methods you can use
to create one of
these objects.
So, for example, if you just
want to change the target--
so what the map pointing at,
what the center of the map is.
You can use the new
LatLng method.
You can just say, OK, point
to this LatLng.
If you have a couple of points
you want to have on the map,
you can use the LatLngBounds
method, and basically just
supply a list of LatLng
positions.
And the CameraUpdate makes sure
that all these points are
part of the Camera.
You can specify a LatLng
and a Zoom level.
You can also scroll the map.
So here, you specify the number
of pixels you want to
scroll over a map.
And that's animated, the
scroll, if you use the
animateCamera method.
You can zoom in or zoom out.
And it basically means zoom
in one Zoom level.
So you don't specify how much
you want to zoom in
by or zoom out by.
You just say zoom in or zoom
out, just like you already
pressed one of plus
or minus buttons
that you've seen before.
You can also use zoomBy
and zoomTo.
And basically zoomBy means,
OK, and zoom by
this many Zoom levels.
So zoom by 3.5 Zoom levels or
10 or something like that.
Or you can also specify just
a Zoom level, rather than
specifying anything else.
And that's how you create one of
these CameraUpdate objects
that you then use for the
animate or moveCamera methods.
And here, on the next slide, we
have a few simple examples.
So if you want to move the
Camera to Sidney-- so we want
to keep its current orientation
then, its tilt and
Zoom level--
oh, sorry.
In this case, we're changing
the Zoom level as well.
So if you want to move
the Camera--
we basically called the new
LatLng Zoom Method on the
CameraUpdateFactory.
And you have to specify a LatLng
object, in this case
that's the center of Sydney.
We can also specify Zoom level
because we are using LatLng
Zoom Method.
And what we're doing is-- we
basically go to our Maps
object and say move Camera, and
here's our Camera update.
And then the Cameras move
there straightaway.
There's [INAUDIBLE].
If you want to animate it--
so here's an example.
We're using--
this time we're using the Zoom
In, Zoom In CameraUpdate.
We are basically zooming
in one Zoom level.
And all we have to do is, again,
on you Google Maps
object, called your Animate
Camera Method and just supply
a CameraUpdate.
In this case, we're using a Zoom
In CameraUpdate object
that we're getting from the
CameraUpdateFactory.
So in this case we're
not supplying a
length or anything else.
That's cool.
But we actually have
full control
over the entire Camera.
So you can specify the target.
You can specify the
bearings, or the
orientation of the Camera.
You can specify the tilt, so
what angle should the Camera
be pointing at.
And you can also specify Zoom.
Level.
So if you want to specify all
these things, just a few of
these things.
You have to use a
CameraPosition.Builder.
And the idea is-- you use a
CameraPosition.Builder to
build a CameraPosition.
And then you use the
CameraUpdateFactory to create
a CameraUpdate.
So the next slide, you will see
an example that makes it a
bit more obvious.
So the basic idea is first
recreate a CameraPosition.
So we say, OK, using a
CameraPosition.Builder--
and can chain all of these
statement together.
That's quite nice.
So first, we have to a target,
so what should the Camera be
pointing at.
You can specify Zoom level.
You can specify the bearing,
the orientation.
You can specify the
tilt, the angle.
Then we just build the object.
And so they're actually
are not all mandatory.
So you can specify just
a few of them.
So if you want to specify just
a Zoom level or just bearing
or tilt or something, you
can do that as well.
So we create our CameraPosition
using the Build Method.
And then we basically just
pass that CameraPosition
object to a CameraUpdateFactory
method.
So in this case, the method is
called new CameraPosition.
And all you have to do is supply
that object into the
new CameraPosition method.
You get a CameraUpdate back that
you can just use in your
animateCamera or your
moveCamera method.
That sounds really confusing.
But it's actually not too bad
when you think about it.
You have to try the
CameraPosition, create a
CameraUpdate from
the Position.
And then you can use it to
animate or move the Camera.
So now we're now animating
the Camera.
But we're also--
sometimes you're interested to
know when the animation is
finished or when the animation
is interrupted.
And if you want to use those
features, you have to register
a CancelableCallback.
And the basic idea is you create
one of these CallBacks.
You have an unfinished and
un-cancelled method--
sorry, unfinished and
un-cancelled.
And that code when the animation
is interrupted or
when the animation
is finished.
And you just have to supply
that Callback when you
actually fire-off
the animation.
And when you use the
animateCamera method, you have
to supply your CameraUpdate.
And you can also supply
the Callback there.
That way you get notified when
the animation is finished or
is interrupted.
Yeah.
That's just about Camera
animations.
And we make quite heavy use of
that for the Santa Tracker
application.
So if you want to find out a bit
more about how we use some
of these features, have a to
look at the GDL Santa Tracker
Android session.
So it's quite interesting.
So let's talk about
makers a bit more.
So a marker basically
specifies a
single point on a map.
So think about it like a pin.
You put a pin on a
map somewhere.
On the next slide, you
can see some of the
properties you can define.
So we've seen the
position before.
So you have to say where the
marker should be, obviously.
You can specify the
title and snippet.
That's what's used for the
default InfoWindow
implementation.
You can also specify whether
it's draggable or not.
That means you can pick
up the marker from the
map and move it around.
And you have an example of
that a bit later on.
You can make a marker visible
or invisible.
And then we have the Icon.
So you can actually change the
Icon that the marker has, so
basically the image.
So you can specify a different
image you want to use for the
marker instead.
And if you use different Icons,
you also probably want
to look at the Anchor.
And the Anchor basically says
how is the image placed in
relation to the position
that's specified.
Because it's right on
top, bit to the left
and bit to the right.
And we have an example
of that as well.
So let's talk about custom
marker Icons first.
Because I think that's
quite interesting.
So an Icon actually comes
from a BitmapDiscriptor.
So it's not just a Bitmap.
It's a BitmapDiscriptor.
And to get one of these,
you have to use a
BitmapDiscriptorFactory, so
another Factory method with
which you can use.
So you can use a
default marker.
So defaultMarker is basically
the standard marker you've
seen on the map.
We have an example on
the next slide.
You can load it in
from an Asset.
You can load it from
a direct Bitmap, if
you've generated it.
You can get it from a file.
Or you can just use it from
the resource, using the
standard Android resource
folders that you can use.
So on the next slide, you can
see a sample implementation
using the default marker.
So if you just use a default
marker icon, you just say--
OK, here's a new
marker object.
Here's the marker options, and
here's the position, and you
don't specify anything else,
you're going get a red marker
there on the map.
But the defaultMarker Factory
method from the
BitmapDiscriptorFactory is
actually quite smart.
So you can actually specify the
color you want for your
default marker.
So you don't necessarily have
to always implement your own
Bitmaps or your own Icons.
You might even just be able
to take advantage of this.
In this case here,
we've specified--
we've added a blue maker.
So you just say--
OK, which hue value do
you want to use?
So if you want to specify
a value, a color value.
You just use the
BitmapDiscriptorFactory.Default
marker method.
And there you can specify a
color between zero and 360.
And that's what's then
used for the Icon.
But a bit more interesting
is even you can
add your own image.
So as I said before, you
get it from a resource.
You can load it from
the assets.
You can get it from a file.
You can get it a Bitmap.
And here's an example
where we load an
image in from the resources.
So we basically have
a drawable.
It's called--
It's just an arrow here.
And we use the BitmapDiscriptor
Factory.fromResource method
to load that in.
And that's quite easy.
But there's an issue
with that.
Because custom--
these images look and
behave differently
from the default marker.
So you might have to
specify an anchor.
So an anchor basically says,
OK, in relation to the
position of the marker--
So will that long position
be specified?
Where should we place
the image?
So by default--
if you think back to the default
marker, you have pin
that the kind of points to
a position on the map.
And when the marker actually
touches the map, it's at the
bottom center.
So at the bottom and 50% from
on left, in the center.
And if you want to specify your
own anchor, what you have
to do is you have to specify
the ratio of where
it should be placed.
So we have u and v--
very easy to have to specify.
And this is coming from the
ratio of the image.
So 0,0 is the top left.
And then 1,1 is the
bottom right.
And here's an example that
shows you how you can use
those values.
So the top right, for example,
is this 1,0.
And here's an example
that I put together.
It shows you the impact
of these anchor values
and what they do.
So we're using a default marker
here, just a stock
[INAUDIBLE] marker.
But we're changing where
it's anchored
to the LatLng position.
So the default is .5 and 1.
So that's the bottom center.
And as you can see, that's
exactly where it's
touching the map.
And on the image you see, you
can see the actual latitude
and longitude we've specified.
That's the blue circle.
So if you make u and v both
zero, which means we're
entering the icon on the top
left, you can see exactly
what's happened here, right?
So the image, the icon is
actually anchored to the
position from the top left.
And if you put a smack bang in
the middle, so 0.5 and 0.5,
it's drawn right on top,
right on top of the
latitude and longitude.
And then here's a bit
offset to the right.
I mean 0.2 and 0.7.
So you can see, so if you take
advantage of this feature of
having your own images, you
should be quite careful to
make sure that the marker
is actually drawn
at the correct spot.
And especially if
you move around.
So let's talk about
draggable markers.
So you can actually pick
up a marker and
actually move it around.
So when you set a marker as
being draggable, you get a few
events back that tell if the
marker's been picked up, if
the maker has been moved.
And that's what we're
doing here.
So again, this is coming from
the Maps API demo, if you want
to have a look at this.
So this is actually
really easy to do.
So the next slide, you
can see some code.
So the basic idea is you have to
make the marker draggable.
So there's a set draggable
method that you
have to set to true.
Or you can specify it when
you create the marker.
And then all you have to do is,
you have to implement the
OnMarkerDragListener.
which as the name suggests it
gets Callbacks when you move
the marker.
You have to actually register
the DragListener.
So on your Google maps
object, just say set
OnDirectMarkerListener.
And you just specify
the object.
And then you just listen
for events.
So there are three events
you get back.
So you get a Callback when the
the user has started moving
the markers, do dragging the
maker across the map.
You get a Callback when the user
has finished when he's
taken the finger off the screen
and the marker has been
placed somewhere.
And you also get drag events.
So you know exactly where the
marker is as the marker moves
over the map.
So if you want to find out where
the marker actually is
as it's moving around, all you
have to do is just [INAUDIBLE]
getPosition method
on your marker.
And that way, you know
where it is on a map.
And yeah-- that should give you
enough information to get
started with draggable
markers.
And yeah--
that's all we have
for this week.
So you've learned a bit
about InfoWindows.
You've learned about polylines
and [INAUDIBLE] on Android.
On a map, you've talked about
talked about markers in a bit
more detail and draggable
markers.
So, yeah.
Thanks.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Thanks
Jan-Felix and Tony.
So we do have a couple questions
that have be
submitted on moderator.
But given that we have a couple
people here that have
joined the Hangout, let's give
them an opportunity to ask
questions first.
So we have Linden and Gevin.
And if either of you are
talking right now,
we can't hear you.
Or maybe they're just shy.
And that's not a problem.
What we can do is go to the
moderator questions.
So let me just bring those up.
And here we are.
OK.
So first question
comes from Max.
I need to draw a single polyline
with a colored
gradient onto the map.
API version two does
allow only to set a
color, a single color.
Do I need to create a custom
TileProvider and do the
drawing on my own?
How can I project getTile xy
Zoom parameters to GeoPoints.
And Tony, I believe you
looked into this one.
TONY CHAN: Yeah, sure.
So basically, for what you're
trying to achieve, I think
TileProvider is probably
not the right class
you should look at.
I think--
I suggest you take a look at
the ground overlay class.
And usually that's how people
use this class that achieve
the effect you're
talking about.
So you can draw in a Bitmap.
And then add the bitmap to the
overly position and then
overlay that on the map.
So with the ground overlay, you
don't need to worry about
all the projection
coordinates.
So in the ground overlay
class, there are LatLng
parameters you can satisfy
to specify the
position, the GeoPoints.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Great.
You gave us a great demo of
overlays, Tony, by hiding
behind your overlays
then of your name.
But thanks for that.
TONY CHAN: OK.
Sorry about that.
ANKUR KOTWEL: That's
all right.
We can see you now.
All right, next question.
Google Map View within a
ViewPager running on seemingly
any Samsung device --and I'm
told any pre-ICS device--
yields a lingering black visual
artifact when moving to
another page.
Any methods you know of to
mitigate this problem.
And this is Linden, who's from
Bloody-strailia, which is
another way of saying
Australia.
So Linden--
just a couple of quick
questions on this.
So firstly you said
it was any Samsung
and any pre-ICS device.
But you said lingering black
visual artifact.
Are you able to describe that
in a bit more detail.
Because we went through
our bug trackers.
And we couldn't find this
particular bug.
So it would be great for us to
post this bug on the official
bugs lists on Maps API version
two but also get some more
Information, so we
can reproduce it.
And Linden might not
have a microphone.
He is typing away in the chat.
So he said in a non-Nexus
Samsung device.
So what we'll do is we'll
give it a shot.
And see how we go.
We haven't had a chance to
actually go ahead and write
code to reproduce this issue.
we read it pretty late.
So if you grab the Hot Fan
and run it on a tablet in
landscape, you'll see it.
I assume Hot Fan is some open
source app or something along
those lines.
So all right, thanks for that.
We will look into that.
And we'll trying to get back
to in the next episode and
also offline.
But as I said, it's something
that I wasn't aware of.
And when the three of us looked
on the bug list it
wasn't immediately
obvious anyway.
OK.
Next question.
Can we have free cookies?
Sure I don't have to do that
over a Hangout but sure.
Offline map fragments
with latitude
and longitude attached.
So currently, there is
no API for doing
be the offline support.
I'm not sure what the plans
around that are.
Currently, what the team is
basically been doing is we
version one out there.
Well, the first release of the
vision two load the API.
And a couple of developers,
Linden included, have been
putting it through the paces
and reported a few bugs.
So I believe that the next
release will mainly be a
maintenance release.
But we need to look into this.
So I'll raise it with the
engineering team.
As with these sorts of feature
requests, what we can do is we
can let the engineers that
this is something that
developers are asking for.
And they can prioritize
the work accordingly.
I'm sure they know
about it already.
It's just a matter of how to
do it and when to do it.
So yeah.
Free cookies.
Pop on down sometime and we'll
see what we can do for you.
All right, last question.
Is it possible to create a
shadow of the marker and its
InfoWindow on the map?
So actually, we sort of alluded
to the answer to this
question in the presentation
itself.
In that, if you have a custom
InfoWindow, you have to draw
the shadow yourself.
And you can do that as part of
the image, or as part of the
view, rather, that you provide
when you set up a custom
InfoWindow.
And the same thing actually
applies to customer markers.
When you specify the image for
the marker, you can go ahead
and actually put a drop shadow
or whatever in the there.
The library won't
do that for you.
So just a transparent
image and put the
shadow where need to.
Jan-Felix or Tony, do you want
to add anything to that?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: No.
That's the only you should keep
in mind is that if you
add a shadow to a marker,
you always make
the image a lot bigger.
[INAUDIBLE] along with
the default marker.
So you definitely have to make
sure it's still centered at
the right spot, using some of
the tricks I was talking about
at the presentation.
Make sure you anchor it
at the right position
ANKUR KOTWEL: Got you, thanks.
Linden has also asked
another question.
So given holding a reference to
a marker is a bad idea, is
keeping tabs of hash code of
markers the best way to keep
track of them?
So you know which marker
go pressed.
Sorry, InfoWindows
not markers.
So I mean, Linden, the way I
would probably do this is use
different listeners or some sort
of identifier to track
within your InfoWindowListener
to work out
which on got pressed.
Having said that, Jan-Felix
anything else you want to add
on top of that?
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT: Yeah, so we
actually had to do this for
the Santa Tracker app as well.
And basically we were
just keeping track
of it the same way.
And we have registered
a few listeners.
And we basically just have
a tag for to each of the
markers, so we know which
markers has been pressed.
So at first you can only
register one listener.
You can't have multiple
listeners.
But if you listen for marker
kicks, so when you want
display InfoWindow, and when
you dismiss the InfoWindow.
So on InfoWindow click--
that's probably the
way to do it.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Did that
answer your question?
Yep, he said cheers.
All right, let me just do one
last refresh of the moderator.
And it doesn't look we have
any new questions.
So thanks very much
for watching.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Ankur, before we
end the show, I want to answer
one of the question asked
earlier in [INAUDIBLE]
show about VPN support.
It's a question asked
by Phung Lim.
So let me repeat the
question here.
So his question was Android 2.8
support IP set VPN using
DSK [INAUDIBLE]
pApn MSchat.
But it is not in Android 4.8.
Why is it removed?
And is it possible implement
a VPN client which supports
[INAUDIBLE]
and MSchat or the support is
removed in the system level?
So we don't always
have the answers.
But most of the time, we try
very hard to try to get
everyone answered.
So we followed up with
the engineering team.
And we get the following
answer.
So one thing is that we haven't
changed anything
related to authentication
protocols since 2.8.
So our [INAUDIBLE] and chat is
supported in the system, then
it will be still supported
latest images.
In ICS, we do L2TP
only VPN support.
But we also add three commonly
used IPsec VPN support.
So if you experience something
like that [INAUDIBLE] and chat
is not supported in a particular
device, there are a
couple problem area
we can think of.
One is the VPN server you're
connecting to actually doesn't
support those protocols.
Another responsibility is some
OEMs may took away such
support in their OS images.
So I hope that answers
your question, Phung.
Thanks.
ANKUR KOTWEL: Yeah,
thanks Tony.
I'm glad you reminded me
that we were going
to answer that question.
So anyways, that concludes
the series that we had
for the Maps API.
So this was part two
of the maps series.
But actually, and we're going
to add to the playlist.
the Santa Tracker episode that
we did on how we build that
app is basically like
part three.
It's a little bit
more high level.
There's not as much
code shown.
But hopefully, as developers,
you're able to get some value
out of it and see some of the
tricks that we employed and
how we went about it.
So we'll be back again soon
with another topic.
And please do let us know
there's special areas that
you'd like us to dive into.
And we can prioritize those
suggestions as well.
So thank you very much
for joining us.
We'll see you next time.
TONY CHAN: Thank you.
JAN-FELIX SCHMAKEIT:
See you, thanks